Junto a un aeropuerto militar destartalado
y repleto de viejos helicópteros y cazas
soviéticos una pequeña ciudad San Antonio de los
Baños. Una + ciudad de origen colonial
conocida como la “capital del humor”.
Es el lugar donde se celebra el Festival Bienal
Internacional del Humorismo Gráfico.
Sin embargo desde julio de 2021 bien podría
empezar a ser más conocida como el epicentro
cubano del mal humor y del descontento social.
Motivos no faltan.
(Cuba sufre la peor escasez de alimentos desde
los años 90 - The Economist)
(Cuba reconoce grave escasez de medicamentos
- Cibercuba)
Allí, en San Antonio de los Baños, es donde
comenzó todo.
Es el sitio donde explotó el hartazgo popular
y el primer lugar en el que la gente perdió
el miedo y aparecieron las primeras protestas
masivas contra el régimen cubano, ni más
ni menos que desde 1994.
Unas protestas que tal y como veis tuvieron
su origen fuera de la Habana y que rápidamente
se extendieron a lo largo y ancho de todo
el país.
Y sobre todo por las provincias de Mayabeque
y Matanzas, donde, por ejemplo, se encuentra
el hub turístico de Varadero. También fueron
muy numerosas las concentraciones de protesta
en la propia capital, en la mismísima Habana.
En esta ocasión las protestas han sido un
tanto extrañas, no solo porque ver protestas
en una dictadura comunista como la cubana
sea algo poco frecuente, sino también porque
es la primera vez que una ola de protestas
a gran escala [al menos en términos cubanos]
se inicia fuera de la capital.
(A diferencia de lo que ocurre en otros países
latinoamericanos, el régimen comunista que
gobierna Cuba desde hace ya más de 60 largos
años, ha logrado instaurar una institucionalidad
fuerte que alcanza todos los rincones del
país. Algo que le otorga a la dictadura una
posición de amplio dominio y control sobre
el conjunto de la población.
De hecho, el régimen cubano es uno de los
pocos regímenes comunistas que, pese a todas
las dificultades, consiguió sobrevivir a
la caída del muro de Berlín y al colapso
de la Unión Soviética.
Y de hecho, el régimen sobrevivió incluso
a la gran crisis económica que sufrió el
país entre 1990 y 1994, una crisis que causó
un recrudecimiento del racionamiento y una
escasez material muy acusada que se extiende
hasta el día de hoy.
Un periodo en el que Cuba perdió, en tan
solo tres años, el 36% de su PIB. Un golpe
del que el país tardaría en recuperarse
más de 17 años.)
Y es que veréis, la Unión Soviética era
para Cuba mucho más que un aliado político,
fue durante décadas el auténtico motor económico
de la isla.
Por ejemplo, la URSS le vendía a Cuba petróleo
a precios preferenciales, petróleo que luego
en parte los cubanos reexportaban para conseguir
dólares;
recibían de Moscú créditos blandos, esto
es créditos a muy largo plazo con bajísimos
tipos de interés y facilidades para devolverlos;
obtenían compensaciones por la presencia
de tropas del ejército rojo;
y exportaban el grueso de su producción al
mercado soviético.
Para que os hagáis una idea, aproximadamente
el 70% de todo el comercio de Cuba se dirigía
hacía la Unión de Repúblicas Socialistas
Soviéticas.
("Cuba fue más dependiente de la URSS de
lo que había sido de España y de Estados
Unidos en toda su historia”. Juan Triana,
economista cubano)
Por eso, cuando la URSS se vino abajo la economía
cubana colapsó. Fueron años de crisis muy
dura durante los cuales incluso el consumo
de calorías de los cubanos se redujo casi
un 30%. Fue una etapa conocida como “el
periodo especial”, años de penurias extremas
que terminaron alimentando un estallido social:
el maleconazo.
(A principios de agosto de 1994, las autoridades
cubanas detuvieron cuatro embarcaciones que
se dirigían hacia Estados Unidos escapando
de la crisis que azotaba la isla. Fue la gota
que colmó el vaso. Cientos y cientos de personas
se concentraron en el Malecón de La Habana,
enfrentándose con palos y piedras contra
la policía al tiempo que lanzaban consignas
contra el entonces presidente-dictador Fidel
Castro.)
Pero, sin embargo, y pese a todo, ahí continúa
el régimen comunista asentado en el poder
contra viento y marea. Una expresión que
en Cuba podríamos adaptar y decir contra
crisis y miseria.
Pero, ¿Cómo resiste? ¿Cómo es posible
que a pesar de todo el régimen siga cerrado
al mundo, a la libertad y a la modernidad
a cal y canto?
Pues, tal y como os decíamos, es algo que
han conseguido gracias a la institucionalidad
que han extendido por todo el país. Totalitaria,
pero institucionalidad al fin y al cabo.
(La construcción político-institucional
del régimen cubano ha sido en buena medida
heredada de la experiencia soviética. Mantiene
estructuras de poder muy depuradas a nivel
de gobierno y ejército. Es decir, no hay
traidores ni luchas internas relevantes.
Y además, el gobierno cuenta con uno de los
mejores servicios de seguridad e inteligencia
de toda Latinoamérica.
Es precisamente por eso, por lo que a pesar
de todas las crisis que ha sufrido la isla,
el sueño de conquistar la libertad y la democracia
siempre parece muy lejano y difícil de alcanzar
para el pueblo cubano.)
Ahora bien, llegados a este punto apuesto
a que lo que la mayoría os estáis preguntando
es… ¿Cómo demonios hemos llegado a ver
las imágenes que hemos visto de protestas
multitudinarias en Cuba? ¿Qué elementos
han descorchado la botella y causado semejante
explosión social? ¿Cuál es el origen de
estas protestas?
Y tal vez la pregunta más importante de todas.
¿Se repetirán y lograrán de una vez por
todas tumbar al régimen más pronto que tarde?
Todos sabéis lo que ocurrió. Así que en
este vídeo os vamos a contar exactamente
qué prendió la mecha y como vemos el escenario
que se ha dibujado en Cuba.
Atentos.
Pero, un momento antes de continuar. ¿Le
habéis echado ya un vistazo a “Si Lo Hubiera
Sabido”, es un nuevo canal de información
y análisis financiero impulsado por Mutuactivos,
con el que participamos.
¿Cómo protegio la bolsa el ahorro de los
argentino? ¿Qué ocurre con la economía
china? ¿Cómo está siendo la recuperación
post-covid en Estados Unidos? ¿Que efectos
pueden las políticas de los Bancos Centrales?
¿Cuáles son las nuevas megatendencias que
dominan las bolsas?
Estas son solo algunas de las preguntas a
las que este nuevo canal pretende responder.
Échale un vistazo porque merece la pena.
Os dejamos el link por aquí y también en
la descripción. Ya nos contarás qué te
parece.)
(UNA IRREFRENABLE OLA DE LIBERTAD)
La Cuba de 2021 no es la Cuba del año 2000,
ni siquiera la del 2015. El país ha vivido
importantes cambios sociales que hasta hace
pocos años hubieran sido, simple y llanamente,
impensables.
Cambios que, si bien no se han reflejado en
el gobierno, ni tampoco en una mejora de la
economía o las libertades políticas, sí
han cambiado Cuba en algunas cosas.
Por ejemplo, y a pesar de toda la propaganda
del régimen, la mayor parte de las nuevas
generaciones cubanas ya no ven a Estados Unidos
como un agente hostil sino como una especie
de objetivo de lo que poder llegar a ser algún día.
En todos los cambios que se han producido
hay algo que ha marcado un antes y un después:
la llegada de internet móvil.
De hecho, este ha sido uno de los factores
que más han movilizado a la gente en las
protestas de julio de 2021. Hablamos de un
servicio que en la isla caribeña no existía
hasta hace relativamente poco tiempo..
(2018: Comenzará el 6 de diciembre servicio
de internet en los móviles - Granma)
A través de la compañía estatal de telecomunicaciones
ETECSA, el único proveedor de internet del
país, los cubanos ya pueden acceder a internet
en cualquier lugar desde la palma de sus manos.
Es algo que ha abierto las puertas a una fuerza
muy difícil de contener.
(Aunque el internet en Cuba está censurado,
gracias a redes VPN los cubanos han logrado
abrirse una ventana al mundo exterior; y entre
otras cosas ahora pueden hablar directamente
y sin filtros con sus familiares y amigos
que están en España o Miami.
Evidentemente este es el mejor antídoto contra
la propaganda política.
Claro que no solo se trata de hablar. Internet
también les ha permitido acceder a información
masiva. Información virgen, sin que haya
sido censurada previamente por las autoridades
comunistas.
Ahora pueden conocer el mundo exterior, descubrir
puntos de vista políticos diferentes, organizarse
e incluso participar en debates políticos.
Toda una revolución, nunca mejor dicho, en
la isla de Cuba.)
Ahora los cubanos comprueban sin fisuras las
consecuencias de estar encerrados en una isla
cuyo gobierno parece detenido en el tiempo,
mientras que sus compatriotas emigrantes prosperan
en el resto del mundo.
Y, luego para colmo está la decepción, la
enorme frustración con el nuevo gobierno
cubano.
Y es que, veréis, cuando Raul Castro comenzó
a ceder los mandos al nuevo líder político
de la isla, el presidente Miguel Díaz-Canel,
se generó una enorme expectación. ¿Sería
este el líder por fin que promoviera la apertura
y el cambio de Cuba?
En principio Diaz-Canel se mostró partidario
de realizar importantes reformas: abrir Cuba
al mundo, permitir la iniciativa privada o
la inversión extranjera directa. Es decir,
el cambio de rumbo que tantas dictaduras comunistas
han protagonizado con el paso de los años.
Y sí, es verdad que se produjeron algunos
cambios, empezando por el acceso a internet.
Sin embargo, todo ha sido muy lento, demasiado
lento, desesperadamente lento hasta el punto
de que apenas han mejorado la situación económica.
Y desde luego no han cumplido expectativas.
Al final, amigos, todo esto es relativamente
fácil de explicar. Lo que quieren los cubanos
del 2021, sobre todo los jóvenes, es algo
muy sencillo:
quieren tener los móviles de último modelo
que sus primos que viven en Madrid ya tienen, los coches
que conducen sus tíos por Miami, poder hablar
de lo que les dé la gana sin miedo a las
represalias o simplemente poder viajar.
Quieren tener un futuro y una vida normal.
Algo que el actual gobierno no parece dispuesto
ni tampoco preparado para darles.
Y eso es precisamente lo que ha hecho que
se haya ido forjando una cierta conciencia
general acerca de que la vida que hoy tienen,
simplemente, no funciona, no está bien. Y
todo en nombre de una revolución que ellos
jamás apoyaron.
Para colmo, la generación que más ha protestado
es una generación que nació durante el conocido
como periodo especial, el periodo de fuerte
crisis económica que como ya hemos visto
se produjo tras el colapso de la Unión Soviética.
En definitiva, esta es una generación que
nunca ha experimentado otra cosa que crisis,
represión, racionamiento y pobreza.
¡Cómo no van a estar hartos! Y además,
no tienen nada que perder.
Queridos amigos, las protestas significaron
una cosa: que los cubanos están perdiendo
el miedo.
Ahora bien, ¿qué fue exactamente lo que
prendió la mecha? ¿Alguna idea concreta?
Pues… Atentos.
(“ÉRAMOS POCOS Y PARIÓ CATANA”)
Para entender los motivos que llevaron a que
la olla social finalmente explotara en julio
del 2021, tenemos que meter en la ecuación
al coronavirus.
En el momento de preparar este vídeo, Cuba
lleva ya varios meses sufriendo una fuerte
oleada de contagios. Una oleada que ha sido,
literalmente, importada del exterior con el
beneplácito del propio gobierno cubano.
Y es que, veréis, el turismo supone una importantísima
fuente de ingresos para el régimen y, por
tanto, es vital para su propia existencia.
Atentos, por ejemplo, a este nombre: GAESA;
Grupo de Administración Empresarial. Es una
organización, un consorcio propiedad de las
fuerzas armadas cubanas.
Es una especie de holding empresarial, que
controla todo tipo de activos: tiendas de
distribución minorista, puertos y, sobre
todo, hoteles.
("Siempre he pensado en la economía y en
el gobierno de Cuba como en una cebolla o
como una de esas muñecas rusas que contienen
otras más pequeñas dentro. Yo nunca he visto
la última matrioska, he visto tres o cuatro,
y creo que lo mismo pasa con una institución
como Gaesa". Pedro Freyre, abogado del Consejo
de Negocios EE.UU.-Cuba de la Cámara de Comercio
de Estados Unidos.)
En esta línea, GAESA controla el Grupo de
Turismo Gaviota, un conglomerado que a su
vez es propietario de los hoteles más importantes
de la isla. Hablamos de más de 83 instalaciones
hoteleras que suman unas 29.000 habitaciones
y facturan en condiciones normales más de
700 millones de dólares.
Pues bien, si en 2019 la llegada de turistas
a Cuba ya cayó considerablemente, un 6%,
en 2020 los resultados fueron catastróficos.
A causa de la pandemia, el número de turistas
internacionales que llegaron a la isla se
redujo a prácticamente cero, y con ello el
Gobierno cubano dejó de ingresar cerca de
3.000 millones de dólares.
Y aunque en 2021 la cosa ha mejorado un poco
respecto al año anterior, el sector turístico
cubano sigue muuuy lejos de las cifras de
años anteriores. Así que claro, ante semejante
situación, cualquier ingreso contaba.
Precisamente por eso, el gobierno de Díaz-Canel
decidió mirar hacia otro lado respecto a
la pandemia y fomentar la llegada de turistas
internacionales sin ninguna restricción.
Turistas que llegaron sobre todo procedentes
del país que más crecimiento del turismo
hacia Cuba ha experimentado durante los últimos
años: La madre Rusia.
¿El problema? Los rusos estaban sufriendo
una violenta ola del coronavirus causada por
la variante delta y, la inmensa mayoría,
todavía estaban sin vacunar.
Y eso, eso es lo que explica noticias como
esta:
(Más de 150 turistas rusos están aislados
en Cuba tras dar positivo al Covid-19 - DDC)
Y ojo que no fue un caso aislado. La llegada
de turistas, fundamentalmente rusos, empezó
a causar brotes en hoteles que luego, a través
de los trabajadores, acabaron expandiéndose
por todo el país. Aunque afectaron particularmente
a la provincia de Matanzas, que es dónde
se encuentra Varadero, el epicentro cubano
del turismo de sol y playa.
La propagación de los contagios colapsó
el maltrecho sistema sanitario cubano y provocó
una escasez aún más severa de lo que ya
es habitual en medicamentos y productos básicos.
Ahora bien, seguro que os estáis preguntando…
Pero, ¿por qué demonios abrieron las puertas
de semejante forma al turismo procedente de
países en pleno repunte de la pandemia por
las nuevas variantes?
Pues,amigos, simple y llanamente porque el
régimen necesitaba dinero. Dinero urgente.
(La crisis turística del 2020 en Cuba es
la que en buena forma explica por qué ahora
los cubanos tienen que hacer largas colas
para intentar comprar algo de comida en el
supermercado.
Y es que veréis, la cuestión es que la comida
en Cuba es fundamentalmente importada porque
el país apenas produce en torno al 20% de
la demanda local.
Hablamos de una factura de unos 1.800 millones
de dólares en importaciones de alimentos
cada año. Compras que se realizan en el mercado
internacional y que se tienen que pagar en
dólares o en euros.)
¿Y cuál es la principal fuente de dólares
y de euros para Cuba? Exacto, el turismo.
Y como en 2020 apenas hubo turismo, eso significa
que conseguir los dólares con los que el
régimen importa los alimentos se vuelve algo
muy complicado.
Particularmente cuando eres un país como
Cuba del que nadie se fía y a quien nadie
le quiere prestar.
Y es ahí donde surge la escasez severa que
ha castigado y sigue castigando a los cubanos.
Es la pescadilla que se muerde la cola.
Una economía fuertemente restringida y muy
improductiva;
un sistema de empresas estatales completamente
disfuncional y no sujeto a criterios de mercado;
un control extremo de todo lo que entra en
la isla… En definitiva, el cóctel perfecto
para el desastre.
Quizás, el mayor error de cálculo protagonizado
por el Gobierno de Díaz-Canel, es que jamás
pensaron que la situación se iba a descontrolar
hasta el punto de desatarse las mayores protestas
de la historia de Cuba, protestas incluso
mayores que las del Maleconazo de 1994.
Para que os hagáis una idea, en un solo día
se llegaron a registrar 40 manifestaciones.
Lo que evidentemente no es algo normal en
un país gobernado con puño de hierro como
este.
De hecho, en los días de más afluencia de
las protestas, las cuales llegaron a llenar
calles y plazas en La Habana, al dictador
cubano Díaz-Canel se le veía bastante nervioso
en sus comunicados. Incluso instó al enfrentamiento
civil entre partidarios y detractores del Gobierno.
Amigos, los llamamientos de Díaz-Canel pusieron
en evidencia una cosa: quizás el régimen
cubano todavía no esté a punto de caer,
pero no es tan sólido como se pensaba.
(Tras cortar internet e incluso la electricidad
para dificultar las reuniones y desplegar
a las fuerzas de seguridad, las protestas
fueron desapareciendo
Las fuerzas policiales y militares han tomado
La Habana y las principales ciudades del país.
Los “boinas negras”, el cuerpo de élite
de represión cubana, y hombres civiles armados
con tubos de PVC y palos de madera se pasean
en grupo por las ciudades para intimidar a
la población.)
Por cierto, las boinas negras, oficialmente
denominadas como la Brigada Especial Nacional,
son un cuerpo político-policial cuya función
básica es actuar como escuadrón de choque
de la dictadura cubana ante cualquier muestra
de disidencia. Se crearon hace algo más de
40 años y visten de negro para intimidar.
Son algo así como la guardia pretoriana del
régimen comunista.
(Nos entrenamos para defender la Revolución
y para defender nuestras conquistas” Adalberto
Soriano Vidal, Mayor de la Brigada Especial
Nacional)
Pero, no nos desviamos.
Vale, puede que aún no haya llegado el final
de la satrapía en Cuba, pero, ¿Cuánto tiempo
más aguantará la dictadura cubana?
Por lo pronto ya ha tenido que ceder en algo
que parecía infranqueable hasta hace tan
solo un mes: las restricciones a las importaciones
privadas.
(Cuba deja de limitar la importación privada
de alimentos y medicinas - Información)
[Lo que, por cierto, resulta curioso. Muchas
veces se habla del embargo norteamericano
que castiga a la isla, pero nunca del embargo
establecido por el propio gobierno, esto es,
los límites a comerciar con el exterior.]
En cualquier caso si algo queda claro es que
la explosión social sin precedentes que se
ha vivido en julio de 2021 ha sido todo un
grito desesperado que, aunque no haya logrado
tumbar la dictadura, sí ha servido para que
las ansias de democracia en Cuba se escuchen
en el mundo.
Y es justo aquí cuando llegamos a la futura
agenda política.
Amigos, seamos claros, si el Partido Comunista
de Cuba quiere seguir gobernando en la isla
no va a tener más remedio que realizar reformas
económicas reales, reformas orientadas al
mercado, como hizo la China de Deng Xiaoping.
En cambio si continúan negándose a cambiar
de modelo, puede que muy pronto la marea se
los lleve por delante. O puede incluso que
la comunidad internacional diga basta a lo
que viene siendo una situación insostenible
desde hace décadas: una represiva y anticuada
dictadura comunista a pocos kilómetros de
Miami.
Pero llegados hasta aquí: turno para ti:
¿Estarán Díaz Canel y sus secuaces dispuestos
a modernizar Cuba con tal de conservar sus
sillones? ¿Saldrá de estas protestas una
Cuba con más libertades sociales y económicas,
o por el contrario el gobierno optará por
el camino de reprimir más y más? ¿Qué
posición debería adoptar la comunidad internacional?
Podéis dejarnos vuestra opinión aquí abajo,
en los comentarios. Y por cierto, si te ha
gustado este vídeo no te olvides de darle
a “me gusta”, y suscribirte al canal dándole
a la campanita para no perderte ninguna actualización.
Una vez más, gracias por estar ahí.
Un saludo, y hasta la próxima.